i went to stockton and grangefield's
sixth form mate so when half the girls
in your class are pregnant
you grow up fast it's not going to make
it into the trailer
probably i remember hearing you playing
it
three years three times three it's time
to go to sleep now and uh
relax and like you said it's supposed to
be relaxing not trying to get through
his cooking but i can get more
relaxation in in less time if i played
it three times
you go to bed and you think i need to
remember this in the morning like i need
to remember to take this in the morning
and you think i'm sorry i'll i'll
remember and then you invariably leave
the house and you've forgotten just put
it in like the middle of the floor
johnny i saw this weird thing in the
middle of the floor like what are you
doing
johnny you left all of your dildos in
the middle of the floor
i needed them i'd bring the cafe nearer
taking them to
costa
rica man what else are you gonna be
excited about i'm amped for the life
hacks
man yes i'm very well thank you it's
been a while since we spoke
i've just realized in the background of
johnny
is i think a john lewis banana stand
well it looks very similar to one like a
very fancy thing to hold your bananas
with
it's like is this to keep it away from
the other fruit because bananas produce
a gas that makes other fruit ripen
prematurely yeah freeze
what happens i learned i learned that
from trying to freeze bananas
they just they they you think like oh
freeze banana and then i like add it to
my smoothie or whatever
and then you take it out until they're
all bruised really
yeah they're very sensitive souls aren't
they bananas
like the problem the problem friend of
the of the fruit family aren't they
there just and then they infect they
kind of infect everyone else as well and
they speed up they speed up their
aging uh so yes welcome back life hacks
if you are not familiar with the life
series
we go through a round table each giving
a tool
app process food
any other particular type of strategy
we've found for productive and efficient
life
and then we riff on how good or bad they
are
so johnny what have you got for us today
of course of course a hot potato for you
what have you got for us
okay so
this is actually one that i borrowed
from uh
a guy who's been coaching me um
which is nutritional yeast
great reaction um pudding i'm just
so i'm so curious about what it is
putting nutritional yeast on eggs
specifically
okay so nutritional yeast
is like very nutrient dense
so it can apparently this is lifted from
the internet contains all
nine essential amino acids um
b vitamins trace minerals zinc selenium
manganese
all that good stuff and it just tastes
makes eggs taste just a little bit
cheesy
really easy way when you if you're
having eggs just a little sprinkle
is it powder it's a powder yeah well
it's flakes
ah see i've got yeast as capsules
similar reasons like is it nutritional
yeast
brew is yeast yeah so that's different
is it i think so i mean i don't know my
yeast
very well to be honest to be honest
neither did i welcome back to yeast hour
here on modern western
east 101. i thought when i say yeast
someone's going to say well why would
you take east i thought i'd have
something to say there
absolutely google but i think they're
different but it's just a way of like
you know i suppose that is the
definition of a life hack right
just a little something little you can
do that just gets slightly more out it
makes the eggs taste better
cognitive performance links to
testosterone
gut microbiome like a lot of good stuff
with
very good how long have you been using
it johnny
um three months
yeah it's just like
so i you get it and it comes in this
really sort of
you know if you imagine like opening
your grandparents kitchen cupboard and
some of the things you something like
your jars and tubs it looks like
something that would fit in in that sort
of setting
okay and it you like smell it it smells
a bit minion you add it to eggs
tastes great nice so there you go
there we go yeast i wasn't i was not
expecting that of all of the different
things that we've gone through
i did not expect yeast to be the first
one uh youssef what you got
ios 14 has just come out
and for people who well for you guys i'm
not sure if you're aware actually but um
i split my life hack suggestions into
physical and digital so
i don't know why why haven't you just
said that from the beginning i should
have really
specified yeah so
ios 14 has a new feature called back tab
where you can set functions where if you
tap on the back of the
screen it does a certain thing
is that johnny johnny is that a dog
behind the area
you tap on the back back of the screen
so if i do this just narrate what you're
doing for people
so i'm opening a let's say
back tap life hacks i've written that as
a
note yeah and then if i tap three times
on the back of the phone
wow so it reads out what you're saying
if you tap three times on the back
if it reads out the screen or if you tap
twice on the back
for me it opens tick tick and plans my
day
that's pretty cool so hold on just to
clarify do you have to
is the is is writing the word backed up
and that certainly is relevant or
just an example no that was just an
example
so if you have the books app open and
you want it to read to you while you
have a poo or something just tap three
times on the back
put it over on the sink so i'm guessing
that this is the same as
with airpods you can custom set either
two taps or three taps to do one of a
number of different items
do you know what else there is other
than open an
app and plan your day so anything that
siri that you can you can even use it to
pay someone but i wouldn't do that
because then you could end up
like well my i think most people's like
if you double tap your lock screen my
cards and my wallet comes up i think
that's for most people
i really like how iphone are making
something that has very few buttons
super versatile like
how can we really squeeze the lemon of
all these like haptic
sensors and things to just have as many
controls as possible
it's cool that they've done it allowing
tapping on the back of the screen
well back at the phone what would you
have on it johnny what would you use
well so i actually have a life hack
related to the new ios
so have you updated i have it is it
is it slim beat or is it in full yeah i
think it's full
full chat not is it like that
it's my home screen oh okay right yeah i
um
i haven't done it yet i should i should
update i thought you did i thought you
sent a screenshot of like that was a
friend nick who turned his entire phone
in black and gray grayscale yeah no that
was a
that guy made uh 100k in a few days
from selling those icon packs really
bloody hell he was just ready positioned
had these little
icons and as soon as iphone launched it
was like up you go
just quickly you said where do you
change these settings just in
i think if you go to settings and you
search back tap
right what would you have yours set as
journey
or what you're thinking for your two and
your three uh
so one would be capture because that's
the i think that's all
when i like need to get something open
on my phone it's almost always like
quickly it's almost always that so don't
forget it
so what would that be will that be like
add a new entry to omnifocus
yeah exactly yeah oh yeah so you that
would be perfect
add a new entry you can do it to like
open calendar in three day view or day
planning mode
resume uh podcast or whatever on sleep
timer
um how often are you going to sleep that
you need to
review the podcast on sleep time
i use sleep timer quite a lot now it's
great
why because you're going to sleep or
just
if if there's something you want to
listen to as you go to sleep you can say
turn off after 10 minutes right yeah
you are you estimate i don't know
whether you can say that you use that
quite a lot because you're not using it
at max any more than once a day
that's true it's capped isn't it i don't
i don't go to sleep more than once a day
sometimes i just go to sleep three times
a day so i get to use the sleep timer
but you're using it maybe seven times a
week let's say
yeah but you're right when you're so
excited about a feature that you're like
altering your diurnal
so that you can use it more that's when
you know apple is like
knocked out really good uh okay so
mine my my first one one that i've been
meaning to talk about for a while
which is how to hide a tag on instagram
stories
so you may have seen people do this
before that
um you can write up everyone will know
you can tag
other users on your instagram stories
that permits that user to repost the
story or it just alerts them that
they've been tagged in it
but a lot of the time especially if
you're trying to get another call to
action out like a swipe up or a dm me or
an access poll
people the open loop of oh that's a new
person
just distracts people from what you're
trying to get them to do
so i guess it stems from a principle
that i've relied on a lot with trying to
drive traffic from my instagram
which is to only have one clickable or
actionable thing
per story so if you are doing something
that involves trying to get people to
swipe up and it's got other users in it
feel free to tag them but get it off the
screen and the way to do that
is to write out the tags and then if you
press on the text with one finger and
then you can swipe to make it smaller
everyone will know how to do that
but if you move that first finger across
to the edge of the screen
and just keep making the text smaller
because the
return curves exponential eventually it
just flies off the edge of the screen so
it's no longer visible
it's no longer clickable but it retains
the tag it still does the notification
it still allows the other person to
repost
and you can actually get away with doing
i think you can max out on 10 tags
i don't tend to like spam tag on stories
but let's say
um this week an episode with ryan
holiday went up so that's
ryan holiday daley stoic uh penguin
random house
profile books portfolio books uh modern
wisdom life and
blah blah blah blah i can do all of that
throw it across onto the far side
and just have one swipe up they'll all
get a notification which might encourage
them to repost or at least say hey i'm
doing some work over here
um and the user or the view is not going
to be distracted
uh from that it's like everyone should
use it one call to action per story so
if you are going to tag someone and you
want them to click on the profile just
have that sense yeah for sure especially
if you're going to try and drive traffic
to someone as like a
um i recently do a photo shoot with dean
and i want to drive some traffic to dean
because thank you for the photo shoot
like new new shot from
dean hindmarsh whatever it might be so
is that when
because wheels sometimes get tagged in
something where you know it's like
someone offering new instagram
subscribers or something and that
there's like
loads of tags in the image is that what
they're doing image
or story story yes
right um or i mean you could go through
the
like the classic year 11 need to get my
word count up
hack of writing loads of text in and
then turning the text the same color as
the screen
you know like turning all of the text
white so then when you run the word
count it actually says like two and a
half thousand words
so you could go once for year 11. yeah
no i know
well i went to stockton and grangefield
sixth form mate so
you learn how to circumvent all the
rules in the most all the black hat
tactics
when half the girls in your class are
pregnant you grow up fast
is that going to make it into the
trailer probably
probably okay so nutritional yeast ios
14
back tap and hide tag on instagram
stories
can we also just as a footnote to ios 14
say do not i repeat do not
upgrade your ios until it is
fully released and even then my advice
would be to wait at least
two weeks after release so this has
happened but to me before where you have
tried to enroll me in the scoby pyramid
scheme
multi-level marketing that is the mlm
so yousafzan the beta
so funny stories attached to that why
aren't you on the beta scheme for like
ios
for mac and the new or like whatever it
is
i was yeah and i've learned the lesson
that chris just mentioned there
the hard way because i think everyone's
like oh don't use beta on your primary
device and i was like ah
that's free i'm excited about it but the
beta like
it's really unstable like to the point
where
you can't use your spacebar because it
just crashes the computer just turns it
off
so didn't you have to adapt your
typing for a very long time i had to
just keep space on the clipboard
and just do control v every time i
wanted to space but then that becomes
muscle memory
and then when you update to the proper
one you end up just pasting random
characters
so that was that was mac os not i've
done ios beta as well and it's
but if you want to use your phone less
and you want a really buggy
phone that crashes all the time be my
guest i'll get rid of the s15
data or just get an android yeah
you'll never be able to use it i think
i'm just thinking you know what it's not
worth it
piece of [ __ ] right johnny what you got
uh so mine's also related to the new ios
which is so everyone's probably seen the
shortcuts thing that appeared on ios
like probably the last update is that do
you
yousef knows what i mean you know what i
mean like you have shortcuts on your
home screen to say like
pay a specific person or play a specific
audio book or whatever form a specific
set of actions
okay okay so i now have my home screen
as like a couple of shortcuts so one is
turn on low power mode just a single
button
turn on low power mode uh today's
forecast anomaly focus
capture um something in omnifocus
or call backer those are like the so
like i sat and really thought about this
i was like what are the things that when
i pick up my phone
i normally am about to do and then end
up on
reddit or instagram for 20 minutes it's
like well it's probably
those like those key things so
those are the key things on the on the
home page and then beneath that is just
screen time
so it's just like here's what you came
to do don't be a dick here's how much of
an [ __ ] you are
and then uh the second screen is is apps
that have a
specific like benefit and then
everything else is just in the app
library so you won't see in this chris
but
all apps are now just put in the the
library so you have to
search for something if you want it to
be if you want to actually find it
i love your idea of having screen time
on the on the home page
just a constant guilting reminder
but the shortcuts things like you can
really get
into it currently there's a lot of stuff
you can do with like i've got very very
basic like the pre-made ones from the
specific apps but you can design your
own essentially
that's good i haven't even seen i don't
know where i've been i just feel like
this whole ios 14's passed me by when
did it get released how long ago
like a week or two ago
normally yousef asks me within like
three to four hours whether i've uh
upgraded to it or not because
i think i had to actually go and and
start the update though like you don't
normally get a notification saying
your phone will update between 2 am and
5 am
mine didn't do it for this yeah my
neither i'm actually i've just done it
there i've set it away downloading
how long is this going it's brilliant i
think it's
one of the best os upgrades they've done
recently just that just customization
yeah because like suddenly you can turn
your phone into something that
you would prefer it to be rather than
just i can't
move imessage so i'm i'm anticipating
all the android users commenting on this
podcast we've had those widgets since
2014
yeah but i don't want to use an android
it's awful it's like you know like
people who ride bikes
being all smoke when petrol prices go up
it's like yeah but
you can only cycle as fast as you can
cycle because i've got an engine
nice yeah seth what you got
having a default fallback activity so
you know when there's moments in the day
where you're just on standby mode and
you're just like
in a whole zone yeah you're just in a
holding pattern
and the amount of time that you're just
on that standby mode like some people
use it to scroll the phone some people
stare at the wall um
if you have a default one then
you you've instantly like overcome
resistance to
things that you normally would never get
done so my fallback
activity for this month is clearing my
like
messy downloads folder you know like all
the stuff that just gets bugged in there
and it's like it's
from four years ago it's not relevant or
like photos on your phone that you've
taken from holiday and you haven't
sorted yet you could do it with reading
do it with meditating
um meditating is a bit of a hard one
because it's quite a like
resource intensive activity you want
something that's like
low effort like clearing a folder or
tidying a
a wardrobe or something that's just like
a big project that you can just chip
away at
in those dead moments i thought you were
gonna say handstands
oh handstands would be great as well but
you do you you
spontaneously invert all the time
yeah i suppose actually yeah it's an
unconscious one like if the kettle's
boiling or whatever i'll just be like
just hold a handstand for as long as it
takes to boil the kettle
and try not to fall onto the cattle
disaster
yeah you did there's been a couple of
times where you've done it with like
all of us will have our laptops out on
the floor around you
that happen to be a bunch of mouse traps
in the corner and there's a
slowly counting down atomic bomb over
the far side and it works
[Music]
activity thing man like have you got any
other ideas on like what
what else you could so i think reading
like having a kindle
on you at all times this is um tim
ferriss's
one of tim ferriss's number one hacks
and ryan holidays as well for increasing
your reading
is to have something to read with you at
all times like you can't read what isn't
there
obviously and a kindle makes it more
convenient for that
um so just having it on your desk and
opening it up
you know you could chip away and
probably fit another book in a month
just in spare time um now it would have
to be something
like the almanac of naval ravicant which
you could pick up and put down something
like the psychology of money by morgan
hausell again
like short perhaps more aphoristic stuff
or just fiction that you're not really
that asked about like linking all of the
key concepts together
um but that would be great i was just
thinking about
how much uh buffering time i have to let
that just sit and wait um
like exporting exporting audio files for
this show
it's like a two minute job to get out of
garageband a two minute job to master it
a two minute job to upload it
and in each of those i just immediately
default
to the path of least resistance and the
most sort of convenient
immediately gratifying thing which tends
to be i'll
send a tweet or i'll go on youtube i'll
do with this thing
and that two minutes expands out into
five or ten and then i gotta go back and
then it's another two
five or ten and then another and i'm
like [ __ ] half an hour to do a
six-minute job
so dangerous so actually like we already
all have fallback
behaviors but when we're not conscious
about them like yeah for me if it's like
checking their
inbox or messages or something and then
yeah you just suddenly down the rabbit
hole
what would you think that might be the
best life hack you've ever because i
think that i think that really could be
so what would you let's try and think of
a way that we can trigger it
a little bit more for people like is it
as you check your phone as you notice
that you're doing something
put it down and go to something else
because you need the impetus right
sorry i thought i thought you stopped
and i wasn't just trying to like follow
those ones no no
tell me so the useful thing about
checking inbox is that that's definitely
my
um like if i've got if there's like a
gap in something
um like specifically email i'm terrible
with email i have no control over email
email has full control over me but
it's totally like mindless like i'm like
oh check if i haven't got an email in
the last
34 seconds you're like why is that a
helpful pattern so i suppose so what
i've done on my
mac is i just have cold turkey just
emails just blocked 100 of the time and
then the
cookie is great it just knocks it out of
your hand well so it just has a
notification at the top right just going
i i remember but then it's it started
tracking
how many times it blocks an app on a day
and it's honestly
it's embarrassing how many times does it
block you trying to access your own
30 to 40 times the first time i turned
it on
i think just really think about that
like that how long had i been allowed to
do what i wanted to do there
how long i would have spent on email
presuming it was at least two minutes
per time
minimum what i love about it is that it
quits it before it even has a chance to
open it's like you're going to beat your
hand to the pizza box
and it just but so if you have if you
find
so as jesus says like everyone already
has that right like whether it's on your
phone on your laptop or any
device so if you find what the thing is
try and block it and then when you go to
do that that's
that's the reminder when you go to open
why do you
why would you sit around buffering
waiting on your email inbox
why would that be a a time for a
fallback activity for you johnny
so it would be like if i'm uploading
something
or siri's going again it's always when
i'm speaking to you guys that siri
activates just wants to be a part of the
show man so weird
um it like even things like if there's a
a loading time on the thing i'm doing or
if i like so screenflow's a big one
um if i'm like waiting for something to
export or upload
even if it's like four or five minutes i
know that's probably not what you're
referring to
like no no no that's that's that's what
i mean i'm just trying to work out
sort of why or where people are going to
be able to find these moments but
it definitely identifies the fact that
our threshold for boredom
has been lowered by so much that even a
30-second
wait is unbearable
and that's not so recent like i remember
when we were
teenagers and you'd have to like go to
take something to the post office for
your mom or whatever
and you'd be standing in the queue and
you would just be like staring at the
checkout
for 25 minutes while doris picks out her
pennies and
um gets the gets the travel money and
all that
and it was just fine yeah being on the
bus man
like taking a bus when you were a kid
it's so it's what's even more bizarre
is that there are people listening to
this show right now
who are so young that they've never
grown up
without technology and literally don't
know that there was a world
only 10 years ago
that wasn't like this people would go to
a cafe
and just drink a coffee
just sit there like like a psychopath
yeah
that's it now people are like oh he's a
psychopath absolutely lunatic
the thing that's weird for me is
thinking that probably like
99 maybe not quite that i think there
was one
year of school life where facebook
existed
yeah it was the first year that i went
to uni it's 2006
and you needed to have a university
email address forget on it
so i was slightly after that so it was
2007 for me when i set up my profile
which was my final year of school and
like it was such early adoption
that you know like you were tagged in a
photo it's like bro brilliant
you know excited you know how novel this
is whereas now
like if you look at people's screen time
on just those devices especially people
of that age and how long they've spent
on those devices by the time they're
but i don't know what this is we're
going we're going we're going down
like another sign of that i think
especially really trying to work if that
keeps happening if you keep like
defaulting back to your
default activity it's probably a sign
that just like
take take 10 minutes you know like it's
it's your mind just resisting the thing
that you're doing
i love that man i never really thought
about that before though that's a
like everyone just has this like thing
they consistently do
it's usually pointless it's so insidious
because we don't think about it and it
just
sneaks up but it's more like it's more
like your um
baseline activity it's just what you do
when you're not doing another thing
which used to be existing but now is
tock or [ __ ] people that are like
pathologically addicted to doing sudoku
or whatever
wow it it's it's it's a downgrade isn't
it you say used to be existing
and now it's something that's i think
worse than existing i agree
uh mine my next one which i totally
forgot and didn't even write down
totally links in with yours which is
never take your phone to the toilet
there we go really easy way to just
reduce your screen time
and an even better thing to do which is
you guys have been in my house you'll
know this
all of the bathrooms that you've got in
your house just have absolutely
hot water
for anyone that doesn't know the water
that
comes through chris's toilet is piping
hot
it's a kettle hotter but the people the
people that
built the extension on the side of my
house previously
got the cold and hot water plumbed wrong
into the toilet which means that when
you flush it
boiling hot water comes through the
toilet which means that it's the
cleanest toilet i've ever seen obviously
it's true but it's also the most
expensive toilet because it triggers the
boiler every time that you flush
um but yeah the the best hack for that
have a couple of books
like again easy pick me up putty downy
type things or do whatever
but if you have a a couple of areas and
this expands out into a wider
strategy about having no phone zones
within your house so i have a
strict now trying to make it stricter no
phones in the bedroom rule so if i want
to use my phone i have to go in the
kitchen
to use it there is nothing unless you're
windows and android in which case
like sorry but there is really nothing
that you can do on your phone that you
can't do on your computer
instagram you can do even just through
the web app instagram.com you can go on
your direct messages through there you
can do
most of the things you need to whatsapp
web imessage
email twitter for desktop messenger.com
for facebook
you can do all of the [ __ ] that you do
on your phone without
any of the compulsive binging and
bonging and the terrible posture that
you get from it
um so yeah like no go zones for your
phone and specifically the easiest one
for that to start with is just
leave the phone wherever you are when
you go to the bathroom because it turns
a
two minute movement into a 10-minute
phone hole scroll and you've you've
created like a
better alternative in your toilet you've
got lots of kind of dippy in books like
easy books to just yeah
right johnny what you got um just
something i just quickly just attached
that someone that i was speaking to
recently said they
only allow themselves to check social
media for five minutes after a meal
so he knows that it's only gonna happen
three to four times a day
and he has a like that's just his habit
so like the rule is
if i've not just eaten i'm not allowed
on social media hard thing to stick to
can you see how that might end up being
a perverse incentive there
yeah you can always rig the game can't
you
but then you just never use your bedroom
to sleep
never go to the toilet
[Laughter]
what's the guy called stephen covey is
it the one who wrote for economics
yeah he was trying to train his daughter
to use the potty and he was like i'll
create an incentive which is
you get an eminem a peanut m m every
time you use the potty properly
i mean johnny would hate that but um
kill me this would
and so she she got really good at it
really quickly but he said she ended up
getting so good that she would go over
do like a drop of wheat and then come
back and be like
and it's like ah damn
you observe that behavior in dogs
constantly where like
if you treat them as a reward they
figure out like the name of the system
activity
to require the treat right clever
little things johnny um so
blobson b-l-o-b
jonathan
this is quite a new one for me um but
it's the
chili pad did you buy one i did
[ __ ] the bed if you forced becca to use
it
uh so there was like a long very serious
conversation
about whether we were gonna buy the
double or the single and i bought the
single
but she she generally doesn't get too
hot
in like generally i'm hot at night and
generally
she isn't she's the opposite which
obviously creates a mismatch
um but basically for anyone who doesn't
know what that is
it is a water-cooled mattress topper
so there's a unit that sits to the side
of your bed
um which you put water in it cools the
water and then pumps the water through
little pipes in the mattress and you can
set the temperature
and the theory is it makes you sleep
deeper
and obviously like if you feel hot wake
up hot at night it solves that problem
so far noticeable improvement
which is cool based on
just anecdotal i feel more rested based
on hiv and some
stats tracked sleep data yeah so
um it hasn't changed um
rem at all it hasn't changed wake up
times at all but it has like
bumped my deep sleep up by like 30
what about time to sleep the latency has
improved that i mean my
my latency is ridiculous it's like three
minutes
yeah like i am i get in the bed and i am
out
that's such a classic big guy thing to
do isn't it
like everyone over six foot and 90 kilos
is able to fall asleep yeah able to fall
asleep supported by their own weight
and they don't their head doesn't drop
either they're just like that
because they've got just it's just stand
by just being immediate standby mode
yeah
but um it's cool like it's expensive
for like 450 quid for a single
for a single um difference between or
what what do they claim the difference
is between
using a thin weighted blanket
and having a cooling thing underneath
you a thin
weighted blanket so because presumably
you still have a quilt but that's more
for the pressure sensation than the
the heat well no it's it's to keep
that's not from losing too much heat so
you're saying
why not just use a thinner mattress
dispense with the duvet rather than
pay for the yeah i mean question one
would be why not do that but then the
answer
usually is i want some kind of pressure
sensation like we're adapted to have
pressure on us when we sleep so then
the next solution is well have something
that's weighted but thin
yeah so i think i think the the problem
you're solving
there is is separate so this is most
people who don't have an air
conditioning unit
can't achieve the temperature that the
chili pad creates
in their bedroom so like even with
window open
you probably would find that the room
was warmer especially if there's like
two people sleeping
in the room you probably find the room
is warmer than the
temperature you ended up sleeping at
what temperature have you gone for
it's like 16 degrees that's cold [ __ ]
hell yeah
yeah so i have woken up one time and
then that's when you realized like
3am you're like [ __ ] hell i i am cold
here
like to the point where i meet i'm maybe
gonna have to turn it off
but if you get back to sleep again it is
just like
you just like out have you um can you
feel the
pipes at all obviously people might
think i have a really nice bed i don't
want to
interact with the way that it feels when
i lie down
so some people complain that you can i
can't
personally like they're very they're
very very small
um it's like the princess and the p
thing isn't it like i suppose it's how
sensitive you are
to what you're lying on but i can't feel
it personally
and i think if you can't just gain a few
kilos of muscle and
yeah propanefitness.com calculator
there we go great can you not
can you not get the chili pad double and
then only turn one half of it on is that
not one of the settings that they have
you can yes but becca's argument was i'm
never going to need my side therefore
why waste the money on my side
i think she thought like it's expensive
it's a problem i don't feel like i have
so i'm not just going to spend the money
for the sake of it yep
what about having two single duvets so
she has a thick one and you have a thin
one
seth please i think scandinavian style
so what what what your method so your
method's great for like
my room is my room is the right
temperature
but the blanket is causing me to be too
hot so
remove the blanket or get a thin blanket
that creates the same feeling of being
wrapped okay but that unless your room
is cold enough which may
maybe it is but most people it isn't
then you need like a cooling device so
option one is an air conditioning unit
which are incredibly expensive option
two
is a local air conditioning unit which
is a bed jet
that plugs into the bottom of your bed
option three is a chili pad
nice i think also the the regulating
aspect of it is quite useful
because i like my room hot at night
freezing by 1am until
6 a.m and then it gets hot again just
because of the way the windows are and
so on so
having something to normalize it would
be good so i suppose the way you
normalize is by
you need a black you need a duvet on and
then you set the temperature that you
are
in the duvet and the theory is it takes
the
like obviously one of the feelings that
probably before has you wake up like
your mattress feels hot
you know you get into a bed and it like
the pillow's cold and the mattress cause
quite a nice feeling
so it takes the obviously you're heating
the water in the chili pad
which is then taken back into the unit
and then cooled and then circulated back
in again
so you you do find that like you don't
feel like you
change it's quite a weird thing to
describe but like the bed always feels
like you've just got into it
do you need to change the water every
night no
how often like once every four weeks
okay yeah that's that's that's a nice
low level of friction
it's like a bit annoying it's like oh
here we go this there's that
time of the month again where i need to
empty my chilli pad
but it's charging the electric
toothbrush isn't it it's something that
you use every single day
it's a good advantage to your like you
paid ton for it so you might as well
yeah you got to maintain it it also
makes like a white noise
sound not by design like or by design
as in the noise of the fan just creates
a nice like
[Music]
that sort of thing good impression good
sconey what you got oh actually you want
to tell us
what the sconey 2020 can we interlude to
the
the problem that you had this year i i
think we can't it's not it's actually
not a problem that i've had but i
thought it's the most scone 2020
thing that you'll have ever heard what's
the before we start what's the elevator
pitch
just the architecture of a scoby problem
i think it's it's a in fact i think you
guys will be able to define this better
than i can
so it's wanting to avoid financial
outlay or inconvenience
like to rock the boat for other people
so looking for a slightly off the beacon
beaten track strategy to achieve that
and in doing so
creating a larger financial outlay in
the long term
or more rocking of the boat i think it's
yeah it's maybe even wider than that
which is like trying to optimize
something and creating a self-created
problem there's a couple of
limbs added on to the scone problem
which include
um fomo and novelty and they're the
compounders so they're the multipliers
terrible yeah such a sucker for novel
software so
everyone you end up everyone is like
friends it's like this it's [ __ ]
awful when you do that on the show and
you're like
no you go no you go um it's
everyone's got a friend who's like this
who's like they'll decide to go
50 of the way there to a complete
solution to their problem in an effort
to try and save
90 of the cost but end up causing 10
times the problem
like giving it to your mate baz baz can
mot it
i don't need to go to quick fit then the
car breaks down as you're on your way to
manchester
yeah and then but you've not got cover
yeah you didn't get covered premium
platinum account yeah no because the
yemeni bank that you bank with um via
stalling
through the monzo uh server
has decided that they're going to close
all of the uh all of the call centers
oh god or even a few iphone screen to
tim's to get repaired they do it on the
cheap then you take your phone to apple
and it breaks again and then apple say
the warranties
yes yes now you need a new iphone
that's that's perfect so
the what it is is that my brother
called me the other day and said
yusuf credit card
is a scam and like what do you mean he
was like there's no such
you never signed a contract for a credit
card you just signed an application
so when they send you their invoice it's
not an invoice it's a statement
and you don't have to pay them at all
i'm going to send you these letters that
my friends dug out of the archives as
like the
loopholes for credit cards and what you
can do is what i'm
doing right now as in what he's doing
i'm not doing it
is you can trademark your name in
capital letters
so that when people use when they try
and invoice you
you can charge them uh or you can find
them for
using your trademark
what's the outcome of this situation
being
to well he's he's just starting with it
and obviously i've been oh we're mid
we're mid scoby problem here yeah he set
up a trading account as well and i've
advised him like look
don't because he's like oh but you got a
risk big to win big i'm like
i'm telling you bro the guy with the
gambling problem
this is not how it this is not how it
works
so is he trying to just never pay his
credit card is that the is that the
outcome
i think he's he's just in a permaloop of
like
how can i find that i mean
yeah how can i find a way out of this do
you think that the scoby
the scoby architecture might be genetic
i think so i've i've got the most of a
handle on it out of all of my family
yeah which is
which is absolutely impressive
actually except for your mum your mum is
so anti-scoby problem
she's analog yeah i mean all moms are
aren't they yeah yeah
i think i think she sees she sees right
through it
maybe i'm wrong but i'd get the
impression that you'd present her with
the scoby strategy that would create the
scoby problem and she'd say
i wouldn't recommend that yeah yeah all
all mums are just like look
just i'll go and buy the kind of dulux
paint and i'll paint it myself
like just i don't think my mum would do
that my mum would
would go to billingham town center to
the
the one remaining boys that still open
there
because they do curtain hooks for 99
pence
whereas if you go to asda they're two
pounds 50 right
have you seen uh so i saw an episode of
south park the other day which is uh
very yeah very unusual for me but it was
about
bezos and um the the workers at amazon
and they go on strike and then
people have to go into the the shopping
mall and it's like this
barren area where like the people who
work in the shopping mall are just like
these zombies the
you know kind of post-apocalyptic thing
hello
what would you like and and it's so you
look at me like oh this is savage but
actually
like and then i'm looking for some i'm
looking for some stuff
and i'm like would you like a fragrance
some shoes perhaps he's like no no i
want
some quite specific stuff and they go oh
i'm sorry we don't have the inventory
and the high street for that kind of
thing
and you you see just the crumble of high
street stores
just encapsulated and i think the
writers are very smart
they're going to drive past an amazon
warehouse
they're pretty big you see that and
you're like like that is one of like
10 in the uk i'm guessing something like
that maybe more
you're like wow they've got that's a big
building
they'll have loads of stuff they bet
they've got a chili pad in there
they've just released south park have
just done a
covid episode an hour-long coronavirus
special
that aired in america i don't know where
it would be
perhaps if you've got comedy central it
might still be getting aired on that if
you've got like the now tv or whatever
um but they just did a one hour special
and um
like the school gets a whole bunch of
new teachers who've just recently been
released from their jobs
and just a bunch of cops turn up all
wearing masks
and then they're trying to get the kids
to start finger painting the kids get
rowdy so the cops unload guns
on the class and the only one that they
hit is token
what's token the black kid uh okay
so heavy so yeah and you just think like
how have they got away with this it's
cause they've got the disclaimer at the
start that says should not be viewed by
anyone
it's yeah that's true so um
because obviously trump has just tested
positive
and he's in hospital yeah yeah so i saw
anton posted saying
he's faking it so did boris and you
think like
okay i really respect anton's views but
like man
man who has takes no precautions about
um
global infection gets ill like 75 year
old with
30 bmi of 30 contracts global pandemic
after visiting thousands of people
across one country
and mocking people not worrying about
people wearing masks
and boris like i'm sure you've seen the
one where they like spliced the video
together where he's like
well i i have no problem shaking hands
and i've been shaking i went to the
hospital the other day and i shook hands
with every single patient
you're like no oh yeah don't do that
mate yeah come on
like come on [ __ ] in charge of the
country right okay my
my my next one i haven't put this on
here yet but it has appeared
on the three-minute monday newsletter if
you're not signed up go to criswellx.com
lifehacks nestle lindale's kevarg
so it is ca it's technically
technically flavored quark cheese this
comes up every life hacks i'm sure well
yes
who knows hrv who knows the entire
backlog and who
claims that this always happens you do
and then off camera we always go
we didn't actually cover that one by
four fine um so we've done
skier nestle lindell's quag is
upgraded skier so you've seen the macros
on the back of this thing it's
essentially no carbs no fat and 18 grams
of protein
tastes like a thick nice
yogurt and costs about 80 pence per pot
it's [ __ ] phenomenal it comes in a
whole bunch of flavors my favorite one's
the white chocolate
they also do ones with tiny little
chocolate sprinkles in
yeah mike gets that one yeah it's legit
man like it's
such an easy hack everyone on the planet
just needs a little bit more protein
like even phil heath needs just a little
bit more protein
and this just have one after each meal
and there you go across the day
across the day that cost you two pounds
50 but you've gained
60 grams of protein was it you who
who said is it easy skier yes was that
you
yeah so i bought some of those his use
of ruthless
window leaking yeah
your window's leaking it's just slightly
open
i'll close it but i don't want to ruin
the flow the knock the
the yogurt chat um or the quark chat but
yeah so i i bought some of those this
week for the first time
and they are i just can't believe how
nice they are
to just quality yeah
like the fact that it's like well then i
think it's it's it's tasting it
and then you the first thing i did was
like check that i bought the right ones
and then check the macros and this must
have more sugar in it than it says
yeah like this is so cool for like a
like basically a zero fat product this
is so creamy
yeah how they achieved that have you
tried this clog that i'm talking about
johnny no i've not oh mate i'm [ __ ]
telling you man
i'm [ __ ] telling you man
on the note of um misjudging the macros
johnny has made that error
once before in a critical circumstance
i've done it quite a few times to be
honest but the time you're thinking
about is when i drank
two liters of volvic touch of fruit
thinking it was sugar-free
on a fasting day and how much sugar was
in it
it's like basically the same as as like
full of sugar coke yeah 250 grams of
carbs just
in and that's the again
so you're in a dark cinema that's when i
did it so like open the bottle
because i can't have any food because
i'm doing all the day fasting drinking
like
wow that's like that for water that's
brilliant
neck the whole thing and then when you
come out afterwards you just glance at
it and you notice it doesn't say sugar
free on it
and you're like
saying you just go to pizza buffet
i did but that would be there youssef
did that when he
had coffee with a bit of sugar in didn't
realize there was sugar in it and then
just ate a panini
yeah same sort of catastrophic
catastrophic thinking there i'm in for a
penny in for a pound
yeah alternate day fasting does weird it
does that too
it's by nature in or out isn't it you're
either eating or not or shake it all
about yeah
so johnny johnny what you got um
so this this one well
no it's all right sorry i'll do that one
later um sleep sleep meditation
in insight timer so there's a few like
sleep
specific um like sample sessions that
are like 10 minutes long
um that are not i don't think that is
designed to be listened to while you're
sleeping it's just like an evening
switch off so i can get a specific link
to the one i've tried i've tried a
couple of them
um really good
like they're a bit woo-woo they're a bit
about like connecting with the moon and
all that sort of stuff but
um like at the end of it you notice a
i think you notice a definite difference
pre-post
so do you do it for a full night's sleep
or like a nap
just like 10 minutes before bed so you
get into bed
i'm not not no not normally no i like
sit like on the sofa headphones in 10
minutes
thank goodness okay yeah i'm not doing
it to fall asleep it's like an evening
like
white to say clean there's even a
visualization they get you to do where
it's like imagine
your inbox is clear imagine all of them
this guy knows me he knows the game
he knows what's going on yeah it's just
really good i've noticed
i've noticed a lot of adverts for calm
yeah sleep stories harry styles
from like one direction has been
i'm harry styles and tonight
i will be telling you my sleep story
it was the local night of france's first
twilight moon okay harry
i i understand mate [ __ ] stephen fry did
one
like i don't know i don't know wow yeah
i'm unsure on those
when you find yourself as a celebrity
like just in situations
yeah how is how has it got to this point
harry yeah mate we've got uh
yeah the guys from calm have been on
again um
i know that we can't play any live shows
this year do you should we just say
the sleep stories thing yeah yeah yeah
it's the france one
yeah all right i'm
harry styles and this is my sleep story
because like when you
got sold pieces the pieces like upsell
while we're in iceland yeah and i
remember i remember
hearing you playing it
at three things three times three it's
time to go to sleep now and uh
relax and like it's supposed to be
relaxing not trying to get through it as
quickly but i can get more relaxation in
in less time if i played it three times
yeah that was mine does that everyone
use insight timer i'm guessing
of the three of us the best shout out to
your
recommendations i should have bought
shares in inside time i see that that's
where like
buying the penny stock and it blows up
that's probably something that could
have been a scoby problem
but it's like the it's when that method
wins isn't it
because everyone was using headphones
full time and and calm and like more
that's why yeah that's what it's
literally what you do it all for isn't
it
um but this is that that is the one
win from the perpetually losing gambler
do you know what i mean that's the win
that justifies the losses
the there's hundreds of life hacks that
have worked worked their way in that
are really good but they've just become
the normal now so probably alfred was
that
i imagine oh yeah all these things are
like yousef willing to put his neck on
the line
and like occasionally he has a bag of
birthday cake way that he stuck with but
there's so many winners left over that
it's still worth doing the strategy
and then you're just seen as an early
adopter of something that is mainstream
like
evernote or pocket or anything like that
like these are all
original scurvy problems that really
he's a pilot
a visionary yeah i think you are man
right what you got scoby
so um i can't remember if i mentioned
this one before
but i'm quite big on loose leaf team and
i know
johnny has been when doing cycling out
caffeine
either a tea strainer or you can buy
tea bags on amazon that just have a
little drawstring and a made of like
sac material and
well like not that like just kind of um
eco paper
and uh it's great because you just put a
bit of tea in
type thing the mesh that's used in
um like tea pigs and other things is bad
right
for some reason estrogen yeah so
in tea pigs and like the silky tea bugs
that are in like the pyramid and are
like really kind of
they are the worst they release loads of
nanoparticles um or micro particles
whatever
of plastic that just that don't get um
excreted
so you end up with just a buildup of
estrogen in your body and you can only
really
um there's something about it being
being able to bypass liver metabolism
and so you need to kind of sweat it out
oh wow
which is pretty bad the normal tea bags
have less of it the only plastic in
normal tea bags is the
glue sealant they use to stick the two
sides together um which you may or may
not be worried about i think you've got
to pick your battles with with estrogen
[Laughter]
so well as opposed to you who is an
all-out full-on
wall oh my god yeah i've got like a
helmet on and um
the body armor the full well yeah
yeah of course why don't you just get
why not just get one of those
cages it's like a steel cage you can
just put the leaves into it it's like a
little orbee ball
and steel on the top you should that
would be like a
squeezy thing at the end reusable and
you can just keep reusing that why not
that
yeah you can do so i i alternate between
both so i've got
it's not actually a ball that i use it's
like a dippy one
um but yeah same concept like a metal
dippy t-strainer
either ball with a squeezy thing ebay
atp well
nice i like it very nice anyone who's
doing loose leaf tea i guess that'll be
good
so we've done sort of quite a lot of
explicit appy foodie ones so far today
one that i've been using for quite a
while is ask for a solution when someone
poses a problem
so this reverses a lot of the
um typical ebb and flow of a
conversation especially at work but also
with
relationships into personal
relationships with your partner or
friends
it's very easy for someone to criticize
anything that you've decided to do or
that anyone else has decided to do i
don't like that
particular piece of artwork i think that
this is
not very good i why are you taking that
route
whatever it might be the easiest way to
shut down
their force toward you
and also to move the conversation
firstly not in
a an antagonistic way and secondly
towards a solution based
conversation is to just say all right
well what what would you do
and the number of times remembering that
i have
a lot of young lads that work for us and
they're all
full of caffeine and testosterone and
they're 18 years old
they're very opinionated they often have
a lot of strong opinions about things
but they're quite unexamined so they
don't actually know why they think the
thing that they think
i don't know it's [ __ ] [ __ ] that
[ __ ] [ __ ] that mate
oh why okay what would you do
not even just asking the why because
asking the why they can often just
justify stuff out of nowhere it's like
it's not enough just for you to identify
a problem
what is the solution that you do don't
hit the track on that video mate it's
just [ __ ]
okay what would you put in its place
and that it moves the conversation in
one question by using it almost like the
a trigger for you to say as opposed to
you're wrong or trying to justify even
if you think that you're right
even if you think the track on that
video is the one that you should have
used
just asking someone what would you put
instead
doesn't doesn't necessarily mean that
you're seceding ground on how strongly
you feel about your side of the argument
but i've just found even in group
conversations as well it reminds
everyone we're here
to i find solutions not identify
problems
here for a common goal so tim ferriss
recommends this
with conversations with yourself as well
that if you're
if you find yourself complaining about
something internally
to always propose a solution it's
part of his like 21 day no complaint
challenge
cool so this is if someone comes to you
saying i've got this problem
or like complaining about something is
it um
most mostly if there's a complaint that
someone puts forward especially if it's
someone
if you're dealing with someone who tends
to be a little bit more emotional
either aggressive or negative or even
overly positive
and they decide to have a problem with
something which is going on just ask
them for what their proposed solution is
a lot of the time it forces them to
examine why they have the problem and
they realize actually it's not that big
of a problem
or it's unjustified it's just
emotionally driven and
sometimes they actually have a
ready-made solution
which is even better than what you put
forward or
if they have a ready-made solution which
is worse than what you put forward
you're now debating solution versus
solution as opposed to solution versus
criticism to the solution
you get me yeah makes sense
useful johnny so i have one
similar to that um which i wasn't going
to say because i thought it maybe wasn't
apple
um tactic specific enough so i'm glad
that you went down that route
which is again something a coach that's
working with us at the moment is kind of
encouraging us to think in this way
which is whenever you're i think really
whenever you're doing anything
um so like any personal behavior or
anything you're like
in the process of doing is come back to
the question of like what is the goal
like what am i trying to achieve with
this and then
like what is my ultimate goal what is
the specific goal and then
list out the possible things you could
do to achieve the goal
and then the possible problems you might
encounter and you it takes you from a
position of
if you're like not sure what to do so
you're like i really want to
lose weight or like deal with stress
better or improve my sleep or whatever
you then find yourself taking this like
i could do
like suddenly you're like dealing with
three possible
paths vectors to that thing and then
three problems you'll encounter with
each one
and you can just pick one and do it and
try it for two weeks and see what
happens
and you can take confusion to like i'll
just do that really really quickly
or so i've done this with like all of my
morning routine and habits and stuff
like that is i now do like
a third or a quarter of what i used to
do because you just apply the question
of like
what is the goal with this thing like
with this behavior
and then can i achieve that with just
something simpler
well like could i not do that and still
achieve the same thing like always
trying to sort of simplify and cut waste
because i think i think morning routines
especially me don't know whether you two
fall into this or like any habits or
anything like that there's a tendency to
like
do as many of the things that everyone
says you should do as possible and then
when you just
reframe it as well what am i why am i
actually doing these things
it's to like feel more mindful it's like
well okay
does like half an hour of meditation
achieve that yeah it probably does
how about i just do that for a month and
see if that achieves the outcome rather
than
meditation journaling like 10 other
things
so that's that's something that's really
helped me recently in like work
training everything
that is very cool so what what's the
what's the process if you were to say
like
problem how would you put it through
that
so define just define the goal for the
thing
like for that area so like whatever it
is you're thinking about like what it
what's the end point i'm trying to get
to and then what are the things i could
do to reach that
and then what are the problems i might
encounter and try and troubleshoot the
problems
so problem proposed solution obstacle
another one test then off you go i think
a lot of the time
the things that we have in life we're
just overwhelmed with this
sense we have like just notions it's
just
emotionally driven actions that aren't
really very well examined
and i think this kind of links back to
what we were just talking about there
that
a lot of the time people just have a
sense of something
and then decide to blurt out a
post-hoc rationalized justification that
they think
sounds okay driven from the particular
emotional reaction they've had
so let's say that someone's i want to
lose weight that's the outcome that i
want to have
okay what are the different ways that i
could lose weight i could intermittent
fast i could just
start calorie tracking i could do
whatever it might be
what are the problems that i might
encounter and that takes it from
the overwhelm of i want to lose weight
oh my god i could do
keto or i could decide to go carnivore i
could decide to go vegan or i could do
okay no break those down let's look at
them individually
let's assess them what are the obstacles
pick a path
and stick to it i interviewed a guy who
did
carnivore and then did vegan or the
other way around
um for like a significant period of time
and he was just totally unattached
to the ideologies or anything he was
just like i'll try this
see how it feels and he said the main
benefit of veganism this is going to
really
upset people but he said it was the
sense of moral superiority that he got
that doesn't surprise me i think a lot
of people a lot a lot of people who are
vegan
especially the ones that have been they
got front-ended into it by the emotive
um imagery that you see of mistreatment
of animals
it's seductive to be able to be that
person
that can say yeah mate but you don't
[ __ ] care about them
you know i [ __ ] i'm willing to put my
life on the line for them well no you're
not you're willing to change your diet
for them
that is true and i i don't know anyone i
i know
like that the argument will always be oh
well i've got to pick my like
pick my battles but i don't know anyone
who is fully fully consistent like
if someone is saying oh i'm vegan
because of the environment
but they're using an iphone like the
number of you know car
kilograms of carbon that it that it
produces or
um carbon dioxide rather or like if
they're wearing leather shoes or
if they they still drive a car you know
there's i don't think there's anyone who
is like
completely aligned with that mission
because if they were they wouldn't have
kids
they would probably live out in a
subsistence farm somewhere
you know there's a lot of costs to have
to go to um
on the other hand you'd be like well oh
you shouldn't throw it you know just
because you can't do all of it doesn't
mean you
can't do some of it yeah so yeah i agree
scotty what you got
just sorry which one think about the way
to make all of that faster so like the
way i just described is like the
self-managed process of like
what are the things i can try and then
testing them so like doing carnivore
then doing veganism or like
trying different ways to like do your
bit in climate change the other one is
like what is the goal
and then who is the person i know or
i've heard of who is the best at that
thing
just ask them what to do and then just
do that
way quicker so like i wanna i wanna try
and improve
my personal impact on the environment
okay i'm gonna get in touch with david
attra
and ask him what i can do you know yeah
well so i think chris is
most well read with that and just ask
them for help
chris i think you're very good at doing
that yeah so i've got um
i've got a letter email actually that i
sent
the other day a lot of the listeners
might be familiar with toby ord
who i've been bringing up a fair bit
recently he wrote a book called the
precipice which is on existential
threats
um and i sent him this email i haven't
read it out yet so
hi toby hope you're well i'm a huge fan
of your work the press piss is one of
the best things i've read since super
intelligence
congratulations on a wonderful book i
run a podcast called modern wisdom on it
i've had tons of authors and things
you'd be familiar with
a concern i have after 200 plus podcast
episodes is just how skewed the
attentions of smart minds are becoming
i must have had the same conversation 20
times this year which boils down to walk
bashing ridiculous examples
of identity politics or highlighting
that we just can't have conversations
anymore
if the great filter exists i'm worried
that it is alive and kicking in the
form of a seductively easy collection of
woke low-hanging fruits for
intellectuals to have their attention
consumed by
james lindsay has a phd in pure
mathematics but is caught up arguing
with people on twitter
he should be getting us to mars not
writing fake intersectional studies
think of it how tick tock must be to a
15 year old some of the greatest minds
of our generation are spending their
time proving why men and women are
different
given how grave the implications from
your book are which is that he thinks
there's a one in three chance
that human civilization will make it
through the next century and a one in
two chance that we'll reach our full
potential
i'm worried the same thing goes for the
amount of press and passion and energy
going into fixing climate change
surely working on the control problem
for agi are looking at a more effective
method to keep biotechnology labs safe
would be wildly more useful at keeping
us all alive i want to use my platform
blah blah blah blah blah to try and
bring this to people's attention
and give them some perspective on the
big picture if you have time to join me
and discuss your work on the show be
honoured and i'm adamant that you have a
big impact on the audience positively
however if your availability is too
tight at the moment i would still be
game to pro
keen to promulgate this message in
whatever way you think i can do
best and would appreciate any advice and
how you think i could do it effectively
so i found a guy and he was an expert in
the field sent him a little bit of stuff
before and said
what would you do i have this platform
that i can utilize
what's your advice no it's a very
targeted example
of exactly that it's like what is the
goal i want to use the modern wisdom
platform to achieve this outcome like
right well that's massive
how do i i'll just ask someone find the
smartest guy on the planet and
email him yeah who is the best person at
that
ask him i like it wait
that's a great email thanks man uh what
you got scope
i was sent a poor man sauna
which is the [ __ ] she said i've seen
you using this
you have i i did a live stream trying it
out for the first time
um and it's called the mihai shyamalan
um
it's called mi hi so i think it's
pronounced mihai
because the tagline is get me high um
and it's chick-fil-a very clever chick
said me hi it's
it's a sauna in a plastic bag or made of
like anorak material
and you wrap yourself up in it and it's
got two heating elements on the front
and back so it sandwiches you in
with far infrared and you get the
health benefits of infrared exposure
without having to have a
wooden setup you get to have the health
benefits of a sauna
without enjoying it at all well
so without
yeah i mean it's obviously the the
experience of sitting in a sauna part of
it is the social experience
the other part is not not being in a
plastic bag
that's one of the main reasons that i go
in a sauna it's because it's one of the
few places on this planet i know i'm not
going to be in a plastic bag
is this the same as the thing that we've
seen
you might not seen it chris but but paul
moore puts himself in this like
tennis oh similar certainly calls the
portable masturbation tent
which is just his head on basically on a
box
is it the same idea it is it's the same
idea yeah
um this is more specifically infrared
and so
you do get uh there's a lot of benefits
associated with it
but i did it wrong first time because i
was just doing it
in pants which means you're sweating
directly onto this waterproof material
which is quite unpleasant as you can
imagine
um they advise actually wearing sports
clothes
okay and being inside and you don't you
don't sweat that much like a half an
hour session
you'll you'll break a bit of a sweat
even though it's quite hot
um so you can tolerate it quite well and
it definitely lifts your mood
you can then have a cold shower
immediately afterwards how much are they
um
300 pounds i think or slightly under how
expensive are they to run
pretty efficient electricity wise you
just need to spray it down when you
finish
um compared to having an infrared sauna
installed
for a one-man one it's going to be 1200
and for it
you don't want a one-man one though
because he's just seeing on your bill um
for a two or three-man one it's going to
be three grand
so significantly cheaper i've sent it
the price
for the same yeah health outcomes i'd so
apart from the fact that it does look an
awful lot like you are
getting ready to die like you've been
praying my neighbors
must think that i've got some like mad
perversions because i'm just out in the
yard
like pillow in this kind of sweating
yeah sweating and bright red and
sweating suffering yeah
so why should somebody
go to that bother like what's because
there's something about for some reason
being like heated up by infrared beams
just feels a bit
like i'm sure it's good for you but it
feels like it wouldn't be
yeah so one of the things we mentioned
on one of the kind of earlier life hacks
was
having a estate change and so chris was
saying that
training for him is more of a state
change more of a frame shift than
having a good night's sleep and changing
your temperature is another great way to
do that so
in terms of like mood and kind of
subjective benefits that's that's one
side of it
the physiological mechanisms so on a
cellular level there are a few processes
that happen
when you are exposed to heat and heat
shock proteins is one of the kind of
ways
mediated but it can improve
cardiovascular health
reduce the risk of ischemic heart
disease
improve glucose metabolism
um there's a few of these kind of like
ronda patrick goes deep into this
um but there's a few kind of things that
you can
you can influence directly with heat
exposure
and then if you alternate heat and cold
it's
you're getting the benefits of both and
it just feels quite nice sets you up for
the day
i really wish that one of us had decided
to
get an infrared sauna at the start of
2020. we would have
so made our money back in this time yeah
me or you would put it in a pointless
putting it in johnny's because first he
doesn't let me in his house and then
secondly he'd never use it
um but in your backyard or my
on my garden seth two or three man
two or three man sauna we would have
made our money back and some by the end
of this year but
yeah uh what am i gonna do
[Music]
oh here's one that i've been doing all
this year which is
a hard rule of no tv on a night time
so i wanted to read more
i also know that i tend to break my
sleep time when i'm watching something
because it's passive rather than
active it affects my melatonin release
because there's blue light
and a whole host of other things also
it's i'm watching
usually netflix which is at best
acceptable and at worst mind-numbing so
i wanted to set myself a rule that i
wouldn't do that
i tend to have a shower on a night time
so i have a trigger point
which is usually about an hour before i
go to bed that's the shower
and i set myself a rule that i would not
watch tv
after i have a shower now i have two
choices i can either go to bed an hour
early
which is maybe a bit boring but would
probably be
fairly beneficial seeing as i'm still
only averaging about seven hours a night
or i can read for an hour reading tends
to set me up
better for sleep um the research around
e-readers is that they do not affect
your melatonin release anywhere near the
same as using an ipad or a phone or a
television
the light that they emit doesn't impact
your melatonin release in the same way
at all
um so i've gone through tons
of books like i've 2x to my book reading
by just having a hard stop of tv plus
i've improved my sleep quality plus i've
actually read
a bunch of stuff that i'm interested in
uh i wake up on the morning feeling
better i notice a couple of nights let's
say i've gone in the living room
i've had a shower earlier in the day
which is removed the trigger
i've stayed in the living room watching
something on tv and then i try and go to
bed
and i'm just in a completely different
head space
stopping tv hard stop and then reading
before bed
yeah reading fiction i think
particularly helps like trying to read
or reading narrative non-fiction
like biographies and stuff if you're
trying to read self-development at 11
o'clock at night i just think you're
sending yourself
the whole point of reading
self-development books
is the retention and then the
application
going to bed immediately afterwards
unless it's
some real clever josh weight skin
sandwich your sleep
in the thing that you want to really um
ingrain into yourself and there's
probably some argument to be made for
that but for the most part just find a
good fiction series like red rising
is amazing i'm really really enjoying
that and everyone that i've sent it to
has become fully fully addicted
also pierce brown the author of red
rising is coming on here once he
finishes the next
book in the series which will be really
really fun and
i'm gonna this good two for one i'm
gonna jump in again and do another one
which is one of yours actually scope so
no tv on a night for me i think would
benefit a lot of people you could
potentially look to partition this and
say no tv
on weeknights um and then on a weekend
you might allow yourself
a little bit of a break but again just
set hard and fast rules about when
find a trigger use the trigger and then
also set yourself some
bright lines around if there's breaks in
that and when they're acceptable
and another one which you have is don't
have a tv in your living room if you
want to have better conversations
so i don't know anyone else's house that
i go to where we talk
more when we go around than yours
because
we don't have the distraction of
watching tv
every time that we go to your house we
always sit in a circle
it's not like we're all in a weird sort
of line like a football match or like at
the cinema
or facing the same way everyone kind of
sits in a circle
and we just have a chat that's
interesting
see i never i never really thought of it
as even an option it just um
like getting a tv seems like more of an
opt-in thing for me than an opt-out
you do you are aware that that's
non-typical though yeah
absolutely i think you're the only
person i know
who is who sees it like that but i think
like that's
that's often a sign that it's a good
idea rather than a bad one in most cases
unless it's something harmful or um
i was thinking about this the other day
like at what point are you
um like really making yourself a
dysfunctional human if you just don't
have a phone
or any like if you have no online
accounts or email address or anything
like could you live a normal life
probably not
well you could but you wouldn't be able
to interrupt like interact with many
other
things like could you have i don't think
you could have like a bank account
yeah so online online banking um dealing
with stuff like council tax with
changing uh energy suppliers it's all
the real
boring i need to keep the lights on
stuff
like how do people over 70
like do this stuff because i i still
find it like
grant yeah maybe that's it well think
about your mum like all of our parents
will have called on us because
i can't get this bloody thing to work at
some point
yeah just becomes the i saw a tv advert
the other day for a
food delivery service targeted at older
people and one of the selling points was
that like you called up and you spoke to
someone and you made the order over the
phone and they made a big deal about it
like
none of this internet internet you know
like you actually speak to a human
who places the order for you and then it
gets delivered by someone who'll like
stop and chat to you
like i can think of nothing worse than
having to do online shopping over the
phone
[ __ ] hell hang on hang on
so you're telling me that i could have
done this
i could have written a macro i could
have had an alfred shortcut
that would have automatically added
everything to my cart but you want me to
ring
on the phone and wait yeah
it's it's changed so quickly as well
like can you even imagine calling up
like a takeaway now
and being like oh we'll have to wait is
it two papadums yeah
and right and one one pilar rice yeah
and like
now it's it's not even the last thing
for me for that's been
dentist appointments so
that was the last thing in my life that
i had to call up for the final bastion
of
the old media yeah it's progressed now
whereby
i can fill in i mean i still wanted to
say this to them i fill in a web form
which is just like a contact form on
their site that when i try and press
book online it just
directs me back to like the contact us
form and then somebody calls me
which is a step better but like come on
like what you should do get your teeth
done by david bretton at the cosmetic
dental clinic and you can just whatsapp
him because that's what i do
all right mate when are you free next
week oh it's this time the framework of
like what is the goal
who do i know who is best at that
[Laughter]
anyone in the northeast of england if
you want cosmetic dental work done go
and see david bratton he's a g
normal like dental checkups everything
full works
just like half of newcastle united's
football team like all of the he's
phenomenal man it's so interesting as
well seeing someone
i met him met this guy at uni in the gym
when he was a fresher doing dentistry
and then
in 2019 he gets the uk young dentist of
the year award
and he's like one of the highest earning
guys a huge cosmetic dental clinic here
it really is
interesting to watch someone on a single
career path
that's yes precisely because most of the
time people kind of vacillate at least
you know you guys will go from fitness
coaching to business coaching it's
a path but there's there's wiggle room
within it right it's like just been
one [ __ ] thing for him and he's just
become incredibly good at it
he's a sniper isn't he yeah well so a
friend of mine who was his classmate
um david bretton's classmate he's uh set
up an app
to solve this specific problem which is
like it's called teeth dot app
and it's like uber for booking a dentist
your dentist.com
yeah i like it okay let's do um let's
finish off with a
a little bit of a quick fire round if
you've got a couple of a couple of
swifty ones johnny sure me
yeah um so mine's actually looping back
to i think the light last life hacks
which is that i'm still
using and still recommend omnifocus
you've done this you've done this
because you know that i'm halfway
through
i'm halfway through it and that yousef's
still using the yemeni tick tick
this is such a i get i get such like
specific questions
from chris and it's just great watching
someone's development
like the problems that chris is solving
now are
very like advanced specific problems
within the on
the omni world
yeah so i i am transitioning at the
moment
from things to omnifocus for my task
management
um the peter aki's course which is
a link in the show notes below if you
want to go and check this out you can
also check out omnifocus
the peter iraqis course is really
helping me a lot i would be terrified to
try and learn omnifocus without that
it really is quite sophisticated
um but i'm looking forward to getting to
the stage where i can
start to fully integrate it and you're
right some of the questions that i've
been asking you about like
is it a task with the subtasks is it a
project how many
subfolders should i have within this
this and this but again
your analogy was it's like snowboarding
it takes ages to learn how to do it and
set up but once you can
you look cool as [ __ ] yeah and you're
carving carving [ __ ] up so omnifocus is
still great
i've i've just written that and i'll
link the peter ackey's course as well
what would what would have to happen
for you to use omnifocus i think for you
to have
said that you were trying it say a month
ago and then
do it a life hacks say this month and
say i've been using it and actually it's
really good
i think it was more than a month ago but
yeah i see yeah
it i'm like i'll set a repair omnifocus
reminder with a life hacks tag
to mention every life hacks episode
until i get it
nice is it cool to see like and i'm sure
loads of people listening would also
love this is to see a um a video of your
workflow
okay i think it would make my i mean it
would make my life easier mate because
i'm asking you a lot of questions that
the back end of your omnifocus could
just tell me
there's johnny capturing it yeah done
cool
uh seth what you got so
i may have mentioned this one before but
if you're at someone's house
and you need to store something in the
fridge so let's say you've like
for whatever reason you've picked
something up that needs to be
refrigerated or
food or whatever but you or well maybe
not even fridge you've put something
somewhere
that you have to remember before you
leave not to forget it there
put your keys in the fridge
so for example if i've like didn't see
my girlfriend we get some
food um ham get loads of ham and i put
it in the fridge and i'm like i can't
forget that ham
but then i leave and i'm like oh i
forgot the ham khaki is in the fridge
instantly you can't leave without it so
i feel you can apply that to like
anything right like if you don't want to
forget something put your car keys on
top of it
yeah exactly right that's the the meta
hack there for me it would just be put
whatever i need to take
put my air pods on top of it because i'm
not leaving i'm not leaving my house
without my airpods
there we go yeah so the essential thing
something i do that's similar to that
which is you know
like you go to bed and you think i need
to remember this in the morning
like i need to remember to take this in
the morning and you think that's all
right i'll i'll remember
and then you invariably leave the house
and you've forgotten just put it in like
the middle of the floor put it in like
the weirdest place
so like so that you get out of bed and
you stand and you're like [ __ ] oh
yeah
and you're like oh god thank god unless
becca goes like just
just tidies it away oh i mean the next
day he's like johnny i saw this weird
thing in the middle of the floor like
what are you doing
johnny you left all of your dildos in
the middle of the floor
[Laughter]
i needed them i'd bring the cafe nearer
taking them to
costa rica um yeah so again another
iteration of this further down the
autism rabbit hole is
um the old wives tale of like tire not
in your handkerchief when you want to
remember something
if you don't have the thing that you
need to remember just get it you're
right you're on a night time you're
asleep oh [ __ ] i need to do that thing i
really need to do that thing i cannot
forget it
i can't hay syria because it's too far
across the far side
or my phone's outside of my bedroom or
whatever it might be just
get something that's next to the bed
yeah and just and put it like quiet
across the room and you're like why is
that
the worst you what you don't want to
happen is to see the pillow and then be
like
i don't remember that's an open loop of
something that i know the pillow is only
there as a signal that i need to
remember it and [ __ ] i can't remember it
it's like when i've saved items in my
calendar when i'm not not like fully
um brain working properly and i'll just
save like
wednesday 3 p.m three months in advance
and you get to that day and you're like
and then dentist calls you and it's like
where are you and you laugh like
yeah yeah difficult one right what have
i got this
okay so um i reebok have recently become
a sponsor on the show
and they sent me out a pair of my own
knit shorts which are their top of the
line
shorts i've on previous life hacks i've
talked about the nike flex repels
which are one of the best pairs of
shorts i've ever had in my life
and i've got the myo knit ones on now
which are
just as good and a tiny little bit
shorter which i think
is especially for british guys american
crossfitters and fitness guys tend to be
able to get away with
slightly longer shorts but in the uk you
look i don't know it just doesn't really
seem to be quite you've got to have like
a tap
out t-shirt and long shorts yes
precisely
um uh so yeah reebok myo knit seamless
shorts are like
definitely one of the most comfortable
pairs i've ever worn and you can easily
train in them they're
probably going to last me for a bunch of
years if those
aren't your if you don't like the colors
of those the alternative i would say is
nike flex repels which i think are
actually called like nike flex pros or
something now
but um basically go on to niko reebok
sort short
by price highest to lowest and just buy
the most expensive ones
shorts are one of those things that you
only need to wash once every few
training sessions not super regular
and you only need like what two or three
pairs of bottoms really for training
and that'll last you for a couple of
years so you might as well invest in
something that's worthwhile
you got them on now i do indeed i can't
go back because i've got the boot on
uh yeah i've only got one that's
fantastic
at the end of this podcast chris do you
just have to try and walk forward
through the desk to
turn around yeah lateral and and reverse
movement
is um and it's my weakness at the moment
uh anything that you want to finish up
with before we
before we finish off i tell you what
actually why don't we finish with a few
things that you've been watching on
netflix
or youtube videos or podcasts that
you've listened to that you've enjoyed
recently
i have one more thing that i'm bursting
to say but do you want to save it for
the next one because this is the very
very end of the episode
and we can open loop it we can open up
for everyone there we go
you and becca watch some good stuff on
netflix what you've been watching to be
honest it's been drying out recently i
feel
i just you know when you watch the world
run out of their con
out of content i feel like that's what's
happening
and you think that some what i think
what's most impressive is you see
the extent to which things are
pre-planned yes oh yeah
and then and then what the scripting the
barrel content actually is
because it's all like oh let's look back
on five years ago isn't it that they you
know
more jose mourinho interviews yeah
every tv show has got [ __ ] jose
mourinho in at the moment weird
i've noticed that the platform
is a film on netflix foreign film
foreign film
have you seen it chris no i've watched
the trailer for it it looked like a
really interesting
idea like it's a it's all right it's
pretty good
it's like so it's it's in spanish i
think maybe
um basically there's a prison with an
infinite number of flaws and a
descending platform that
starts on floor one or floor zero with
loads of food on it so enough for all of
the levels
but every month people get put to sleep
and reallocated randomly onto a floor
so you might be put right at the bottom
or right at the top so it's basically
like
an experiment in game theory so if
everybody just took their portion
and the whole thing plays out and it's
uh it's pretty graphic but
just quite a like quite so it came out i
think at the time when everyone was like
panic buying toilet roll and
and so it's like a macro commentary on
that
so it's quite good clever idea i really
like that have you watched anything
sounds very sort of black mirroring i
tried to watch the social
dilemma social experiment social timer
yeah um
so about half of it like it's it's fine
but like
i think i guess having listened to like
tristan harris's
podcast and stuff is it's not it's not
anything new but i imagine for a lot of
audiences they will be like
this is brilliant um also
la casa de papel is very good
bless you uh that's well it's called
money heist so it's in spanish oh okay
um that it's way bigger than i thought
i thought it was kind of a niche showed
she's really bad at arts and spanish but
like the
the following for that show is
absolutely huge
all of the actors in them have got sort
of 16 million followers on instagram and
stuff like that
they're seriously is it like a
multi-series thing or is it just one
multi-series yeah season four is out now
or something i think really
i think so yeah it's very very well
executed like really well shot very
um i would recommend it do you watch it
dubbed or with subtitles
alternate sometimes someone will say
something really silly and you but i
wanna wonder what that sounds like in
spanish
and then you'll like go back to the
dubbed again
it's not a terrible dubbing as well like
some
you know we were talking about this last
time like some dubbing and it's like hey
who's there oh
ruins it um have you watched murder next
door
no is that the american thing the
american i just watched that last night
with becca
my god holy [ __ ]
you would really i think you'd really
enjoy it you said because it kind of
like subverts a lot of your expectations
so a a similar to the staircase
it's just a single a single watch um the
staircase is a long the staircase is a
long burn
this is like being fired out of a cannon
um
it's okay it's not having a terrible
couple of years isn't it
it's a terrible decade
been financially ruined i'm still in
prison and this is still going on yeah
but um yeah that american thing what is
it called murder next door i thought
it's called american murder or something
oh [ __ ] yeah maybe it is maybe it is
american murder
perhaps either way it's serious
um a wife and her two children a
pregnant wife and her two children go
missing
and the police try and find out what
happens and it's just a
it's a roller coaster what's so cool
about it is
it uses a lot of her like social media
so she she's obviously big with facebook
live
did a lot of facebook live a lot of
videos a lot of photos
traffic traffic trying to get traffic
let's just look yeah so you're trying to
insert impressions but yeah so she's
obviously very active on that
and it like documents a story with like
real police footage and that
so it splice makes it like it's the
first time i've ever seen them splice in
police body cam footage
i know they've bought the rights to
police but so imagine
how difficult it must be to go to like
washington state pd and say hey guys
we're netflix we want the right to
your body cam footage and the
um interview room corner of the
wall recording and the audio recording
and the
polygraph test that people take we want
we want everything please
it just wouldn't like in the uk like in
so in the us you'd have legal
problems you'd have to have a team of
lawyers that are sorting through all the
paperwork
in the uk you'd be dealing with
catherine from
um team of the variety that well you
cannot because it's unfloppy disk and we
haven't got the converter so
like catherine catherine would only be
able to allow you
to take a recording on your phone of her
vga monitor
that would be the way have you facts and
then fax it back
to yourself from yeah but what i was
thinking while i was watching it was
i don't think there was anything in
there that wasn't just
accessed footage so like that's a
netflix documentary that's been made by
some bloke on
final cut you know no there's they're
flying there's drone shots over the top
of the town
[Music]
right there's some production stuff in
there but it's
my point is oh it's very minimal it's
all been done
in covid parameters isn't it oh yeah
yeah yeah
which is bonkers like just for someone
to think we really need to get something
out there
let's just find loads of footage and a
story and
piece it all together and then up
documentary library made documentary
yeah
but man it's heart-wrenching the the
story
it's about right um the fall on netflix
is
just i put it in the newsletter the full
with
um oh god people are going to be
screaming down there down the airport i
mean the guy
from 50 50 shades of grey yeah anyway
him 58 a great uh not robert pattinson
he's the
vampire man i'm sorry williams the guy
used to be in take that yes did a solo
yes yes yeah and then he went back to
take that
um yeah the fall absolutely awesome it's
got julian anderson from x-files in it
she's got big fake boobies and it's
three seasons of
really ruthless very dark very subverted
like it's it's interesting you should
watch it you should watch it it's really
fun
nice well i'm gonna persist i'm sorry
i'm adding those two to the list and i'm
gonna persist with the staircase if you
say
it's a slow burner because it feels like
the first
the first two episodes are just like
like
two minutes of um stuff just bumped out
into an hour
i would i so i gave up on it the first
time i tried to watch it
okay chris was like you should just
watch it
like becca and i like sat back down and
i'm like right okay you're gonna have to
like grip through this and you get past
the point and you're like
oh god like it suddenly it like
cool so it's the the fact that it's a
little bit of a slow burner it actually
plays to its strength
because you can't believe that it's
still going it's like it can't it
can't be more there's more there's more
it right
and then it jumps like 10 years later to
the present day and you're like
what sorry this is still going
if you met his lawyer yet
yeah you'll love him with with the like
the mullet
yeah yeah yeah there's a scene in it
where i actually thought of you
where he it's like the day before he's
due to give opening statements
and someone's like messed up the slides
oh when he loses his [ __ ] at the guy
he's like
i am about to go out and give and you
are messing around
brilliant but he throughout the whole
thing i think is
fantastic like just the arguments the
way that he presents his arguments
i'm always so in awe of lawyers i just
think they're such impressive people
well the guy the accused in the
staircase is really rich
and i'm gonna guess that the particular
lawyer i can't remember but i'm gonna
guess he must have
found who's the guy with the the largest
penis
in this particular what is the goal who
is the person who is better
email them email them the scene where
he's like giving him the rundown like
the invoice basically of what this is
going to cost
have you got club no oh no you'd love it
so he's just gone to like lawyers.com
sought by
price size of meatus
selected number one sorted by
density of glands
brilliant oh man i wish i i'm always so
jealous of you because whenever we like
say a new series so like i've seen all
of the fall for example
i like i watched it when it was on bbc a
couple years ago um
you guys have got a lot of power though
because you're like the the stuff that
you recommend i'm like right it's
it's getting it's just such a great
position because like i suppose i do the
same
with tv as you do with protein powder
like you occasionally find one that's
like i need to tell people about this
you have to sit through you know and i
and i feel like what you get is the
the cream of something i totally trust
you as well because i think like
anything you have there's nothing you
recommended that i've been like i was a
bit
so we should exploit that chris i agree
i agree indeed just
just send some really bad ones through
yeah no
look boys thank you so much for coming
on
if people want to get some business
coaching
if they're offline pt who wants to go
online head to propanefitness.com
modern wisdom and if you want to
get some macros just propanefitness.com
and it'll get you lean
exactly absolutely i'll go to both
and what do they get if they go to the
slash modern wisdom it's that
you won't believe the seven things that
will what is it
it's it's like the thing of all the free
training we've ever given away it's the
thing that's had the
the most positive feedback especially
like the last third
there is so much money in it open that
loop man
open that loop but yes if you're a pt
who's looking to transition online
obviously this year has been the year of
doing [ __ ] online
preppingfitness.com modern wisdom go and
check it out
i'll just give the boys a message
they're on instagram just give them a
message i'm sure that they'll
answer any of your questions before you
need to sink your teeth into too much
more
um we'll be back with probably a
catch-up episode i guess we've done
a little bit of time we've probably had
a bit of life go on uh life hacks 114
and then i'm tempted to start the
relationship series or the business
principles series back up again as well
oh yeah they were fun and that's next
i'll reveal the the one life hack that
you won't believe
that yeah
so i would also be keen for if anyone
has suggestions for
new series in the comments any new big
topics to
sink into as long as they're not like
really sensitive or like
yeah i'm not going to list ones because
it just gives people ideas on what you
don't want to talk about
the internet's listening man look boys
thank you so much for your time ladies
and gentlemen
okay thanks
bye then
you